I don't log into Facebook often but the
last time I did I was super impressed by
its simple intuitive and fast new UI in
today's video I'll show you how to
reverse engineer some of its UI features
specifically the top navigation bar is
icon buttons and this multi-level
animated drop-down will do it using HTML
CSS and because I mentioned the word
Facebook I'm legally obligated to use
react in this demo in the following code
tutorial you'll learn how to create icon
buttons with flexbox you'll learn how to
use CSS transforms to create sliding
animations and fundamental concepts in
react white component composition hooks
and how to create CSS animations based
on the state of your react application
and I'll throw in a bunch of other cool
tips along the way if you're new here
like and subscribe and let me know if
you want to see more beginner friendly
UI tutorials like this in the comments
before we get started let's take a
closer look at what we're building today
by the end of this video
you'll have several reusable react
components that you can use for
navigation and drop downs at the top we
have a navbar component where the
children are nav items represented at
icon buttons these buttons have children
that you can toggle on or off by
clicking them when we click the carrot
it renders our drop down component it
contains multiple drop down items and
the ones with a chevron can toggle to a
secondary drop down menu notice how the
hold menu slides out to the left and the
new one comes in from the right and
because the height of the two menus
won't be the same we'll animate that as
well now before we get started I'd just
like to say this is a beginner friendly
video but we move at a very fast pace on
this channel so feel free to pause the
video or slow down the playback speed as
you follow along the first thing we'll
need is a react app assuming you have no
js' installed open up the command line
and run npx create react app and of
course the name of our app is Facebook
to keep this demo simple I'm going to
delete everything that's not the index
JSF KS or index dot CSS files the
index.js file is your initial entry
point I'll go ahead and remove the
serviceworker stuff here then you can
ignore this file for the rest of the
video from there I'm removing all the
boilerplate code from the app.js file
will be using functional react
components in this video when you see a
function whose name starts with a
capital letter you can think of that as
a component the return value of a
functional component is your UI or HTML
or more specifically JSX JSX is not
actually HTML but it's a syntax
extension for JavaScript that allows you
to write HTML like templates in your
components
but before we get too deep into react
let's open up the index CSS file the CSS
in this video is pretty generic so feel
free to use it with your favorite
framework I'm starting by defining some
global CSS variables that we can think
of as our theme and I'm also defining a
speed variable that represents the
animation speed which will come into
play later in the video then below that
I'm overriding the default unordered
list style and then for our link
elements I'll match them to the text
color variable in our color scheme that
takes care of our initial setup now
we're ready to start building the top
navigation bar react and especially
functional components make it really
easy to break your application down into
a lot of small reusable pieces and this
is a practice that we call a component
composition in our App J's file we'll
define a new component named navbar and
it returns JSX inside these parentheses
we'll go ahead and add an HTML nav
element with an unordered list inside of
it we can apply a CSS class to these
elements using class name notice how
this is different than regular HTML
which is normally just class and we'll
apply a class for navbar and navbar now
have to make these elements easy to
style now if we go up to the JSX for the
app component we can declare this navbar
there and notice how we declare it
almost like a regular HTML element now
I'm going to open up the CSS here on the
right side and we'll apply some styles
to the navbar the navbar is basically
just a rectangle that sits at the top
we'll give it a fixed height based on
our nav size variable and then some
coloring and padding the unordered list
that sits inside the nav is the
container for the children which we'll
set up as a flexible row we want it to
take up 100% of the width and the height
of the parent and then we'll set the
display property to flex and we could
have all the children's start on the
right-hand side instead of the default
left side by saying justified content
flex and now at this point we have some
actual UI that we can take a look at go
ahead and run NPM start from the command
line to serve your app it should open in
the browser automatically and you should
see this horizontal gray bar up at the
top and now the question becomes how do
we add items or children inside the
navbar in react components can pass data
and UI elements to each other using
props add props as an argument to your
function and then you can reference it
in your template props has a built in
property name children and it will
project or reference any UI elements
that you pass in inside of the actual
of that component for example if we go
up to our navbar and add a list item
inside of its tags it will be rendered
in the location that we called prop
stock children so if we open up the
browser you should see the letter X here
up in the top left corner but this gives
us a great opportunity to create a new
component called a nav item our nav item
component will also take props and we'll
set up a list item as its main element
and then we'll nest in a or link element
inside of it the a element represents
the icon button so we'll give it a CSS
class accordingly now this time instead
of referencing props children we're
going to pass our own custom prop called
an icon instead of adding UI elements
inside of the tags we reference our icon
prop as we would with a regular HTML
attribute so props allow you to pass
data from the parent to the child
similar to how you might pass an
argument to a JavaScript function
because remember your react component is
just a JavaScript function for now I'm
just going to pass some emoji icons so
we can focus on the CSS each nav item is
a box that is slightly smaller than the
nav bar itself an easy way to manage its
width is to calculate it dynamically so
we'll take our nav size variable which
is 60 pixels and we'll multiply it by
0.08 or 80% with the calc function now
each of these now items should display
their children directly in the center we
can easily do that with flexbox by
aligning items to the center and just
find the content to the center so that
gives us a box with its children in the
middle but now we want an icon button
with a circular shape I'm going to scope
a new CSS variable to this class called
button size it also uses the calc
function to give us a size that is
exactly 50% of the original navbar size
and now we can apply that value to the
width and the height of this class and
then to make the shape circular we can
apply a border radius of 50% which
creates a perfect circle now inside of
this circle we also want to Center the
children directly in the middle so again
we'll set up a Flex container and a line
and justify everything to the center if
you open your app in the browser you
should now see these three icon buttons
here at the top as an added touch we
might want to change the color slightly
when these items are hovered over an
easy way to handle that is with a CSS
transition we'll apply it to the filter
property and set it to a duration of 300
milliseconds then we'll target the hover
cito selector on the icon button and
we'll filter its brightness to 1.2 to
make it slightly brighter as we have
over it however in the full demo and on
Facebook you'll notice that it's using
SVG icons you can find all the SVG s I
used in the source code on github they
live in this icons directory but how do
we use these SVG icons and react it's
actually very easy to use an SVG icon as
a react component directly in your code
at an import statement to the top of the
file that references the path to your
SVG icon you import a react component
and then name it whatever you want using
the as keyword and then you can do the
same thing for all the other SVG is that
you want to use in your code from there
we can go back down to our navbar and
instead of using an emoji
we'll use braces to pass on one of our
SVG components directly and now your
icon buttons can handle both SVG
graphics and emoji strings equally but
your SVG's don't inherit a size by
default so we'll want to go ahead and
set a fixed width and height for them
and now if we preview things in the
browser we should have an icon nap that
is very similar to the actual facebook
UI and now we're ready for the fun part
building an animated multi-level
drop-down menu now the reason we're not
passing the icon as a direct child of an
ad item is because some of our nav items
might have a drop-down menu and we want
that to serve as the children we'll add
a fourth nav item here with a carrot
icon and our drop-down will go inside of
it
now in order to open and close a drop
down our nav item will need to have some
state or in other words some data that
changes throughout the lifecycle of the
app we can manage state and react using
a hook called use state in our nav item
components we call the use state
function and it returns us with two
values the values are returned in an
array so we can D structure them as
variables here using bracket the first
value is the state which in our case is
called
open and is a boolean value that tells
us whether or not the drop-down menu is
open the second value is a function that
you can use to change the state we can
also set a default value as the argument
to use state and of course we want the
drop-down to be closed by default that
sets up the initial state but now we
want the user to be able to change the
state when they click on the nav item
button we can do that by going down to
our link element and we'll add an on
click event handler when the user clicks
a button it will use the set open
function that we got from new state and
it will flip the open value to the
opposite of whatever it currently is
putting a bang in front of a boolean
gives you its opposite value and that
can be useful for toggling things on and
off okay so now that user has a way to
toggle
State but now we need to do something
useful with the state in our case we
want to show the drop down when the open
state is set to true below the link will
add braces and if the open property is
true then we'll show the prop stock
children if the open state is false then
nothing will be shown here we can test
things out by going to our nab item
component adding a hello world and you
should see that appear when you click on
the button obviously it looks terrible
so let's make a drop down component to
fix that we'll add another function for
drop down menu and we'll have it return
a div with a class of drop-down then
we'll add our drop down menu as the
child of the nav item now similar to our
nav bar a drop down has multiple drop
down items but in this example I'm going
to nest that component directly in the
drop down menu the drop down item will
simply be a link with a class name of
menu item and then we'll pass and props
children to control the text of that
link now you may have noticed in the
demo that some of these links have an
icon on the left and some have an icon
on the right we can handle that logic in
a flexible way by adding slots for a
left icon and a right icon when you pass
in a left icon or right icon prop it'll
be rendered but if you leave it blank
then it just won't render anything at
all we can see it and use down here in
the drop down a basic drop down item
we'll just take some text as a child but
if you want to show an icon on the left
or right you can also pass in the icon
prop and pass it a component or emoji
string now in order to get things
looking right let's go back to our CSS
the drop down menu on Facebook overlaps
just slightly with the top navbar and we
can achieve that effect by using
absolute positioning it allows us to
explicitly offset an element based on
its container from the top of the parent
nav bar will move the drop down down 558
pixels that means it'll overlap by 2
pixels with the top nav bar which has a
height of 60 we can give it a fixed
width of 300 pixels and then we'll move
it over to the left by translating it
over the x-axis by 45% we'll give it
some colors and padding and we'll want
to make sure the overflow property is
set to hidden what this will do is hide
any child elements if they overlap this
container that's important because in a
minute here
we'll be sliding in multiple menus
through this container now the drop down
has multiple menu items we'll set these
up as Flex containers that align their
items to the center in the context of a
row that means vertical alignment now
when a user hovers over a menu item
we want to animate the background color
so we'll go ahead and set up a
transition for the background then we
can target the menu items hover pseudo
selector and change the background color
to something a little bit lighter as a
final touch we want the right icon in
the row to be pushed all the way to the
right side with flexbox
you can set the left margin of the last
item to auto and that will push it all
the way to the right and everything else
to the left and now our drop down menu
is starting to take shape at this point
we have a fully functional single level
drop down but we require an animated
multi level drop down to help us along
the way we'll install a very popular
package called react transition group it
will help us control the conditional
logic for rendering multiple menus and
transitioning between them when they're
added or removed from the application
once installed go ahead and import the
CSS transition component from the
package then we need to give our
drop-down menu some state to specify
which menu is currently visible we'll
set the main menu as the default and
then we'll also show a settings and
animals menu as well now our active menu
is the state or the name of the menu and
set active menu is how we change it now
that we have state we can animate
elements in or out using CSS transition
we can go ahead and wrap our current
drop-down elements in the CSS transition
component it's looking for a prop of in
which when truthy will render and
animate its children into the UI in
other words when the active menu equals
main then we want to show the children
inside of this component I'm also adding
a second property called unmount on exit
which completely removes these children
when they're not active next we'll set a
timeout which defines the duration of
the animation and the last prop we need
to add here is class names which we'll
set to menu primary for this primary
main menu now here's how the CSS
transition actually works it looks for
the first child element which we'll set
up here as it did then when it's in prop
changes it will add or remove CSS
classes to this element based on the
state of the animation and it uses the
class names prop to prefix those classes
CSS transition doesn't actually animate
anything directly instead it adds and
removes classes based on the state of
the animation so you can handle the
animations in your CSS notice how I'm
setting up four different classes here
menu primary enter interactive exit and
exit active when the in prop first
becomes true it will add the menu
primary enter class to the div after a
timeout of 500ml
it then adds the menu primary
interactive class
now when the in prop becomes false it
does the exact opposite it adds the exit
class than the exit active class this
means you can easily create an animation
using CSS transitions we want our main
menu to slide in from left to right so
initially we'll translate it to the left
by a hundred and ten percent so it'll be
completely invisible off to the left
after five hundred milliseconds
we'll bring the translate back to zero
so it'll be in its normal position then
we can animate it using the transition
property using our speed variable and a
timing function of ease as you can see
here CSS is doing the animation while
react is toggling the classes for you
now to animate out will do basically the
same thing just in the opposite
direction we'll translate from zero to a
negative one hundred and ten percent now
at this point everything should be
exactly the same that's because we need
a secondary menu to toggle to let's get
started with that second menu by copying
our CSS transition and pasting it
directly under the existing one instead
of checking the active menu for main
we'll check the active menu for settings
for class names
we'll use menu secondary because we want
to set up different classes for this
menu to slide from right to left now the
class is worth in exactly the same way
the only difference is that we're
translating to positive 110 percent
versus negative 110 percent the effect
is that the secondary menu will be
offset to the right and then it will
slide in to the left and that's all it
takes to build the basic slide in
slide-out animation but we are missing
one piece of the puzzle and that's a way
for the user to activate or deactivate a
menu we have our set active menu
function from you stayed so we'll go
ahead and bind that to the click event
on the drop-down item button but instead
of hard-coding a value here we're going
to look for a prop that's passed down
from the parent component and we'll want
to make sure that prop exists before we
call the set active menu function now to
get our demo working we can go down to
any drop-down item and set the go to
menu prop to whatever menu we want to
navigate to which in our case will
either be settings or main and now if
you open up your demo you should have a
functional multi level drop-down but
we're not done quite yet there's still
some additional polish that we have to
take care of go back to your demo and
add a bunch of drop-down items to one of
the menus notice how the height is not
animated it just snaps into place and
totally ruins the entire animation this
happens because the old menu hasn't been
completely removed from the
by the time the new menu is visible what
we need is a more dynamic way to manage
the height let's create some state for
the height of the menu then we'll create
a function called calculate height and
this function takes a Dom element as its
argument
that's because a Dom element has a
property called offset height which
contains the actual height and pixels of
that element and now you might be
wondering where do we get this element
and when do we call this function well
the CSS transition has lifecycle hooks
that we can tap into one of these hooks
is on Enter it calls a callback as soon
as the enter class is first added to the
element and it also provides the element
as an argument which means we can simply
pass in our calc I function here as the
prop value that will recalculate the
height of the menu now we just need to
apply it as a style to the drop down
itself we can go up to the style
attribute and dynamically pass in the
height from our state and that leaves us
with one final step to animate it go to
the drop down class in your CSS and add
a transition for the height now when you
go back to the demo your drop down
should magically shrink and grow based
on the size of the current menu and with
that I'm gonna go ahead and wrap things
up there if this video helped you please
like and subscribe and let me know what
you want to see next in the comments
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one
[Music]
you